commuters were on their way to work
when the bombs started this was Terror
and Mayhem reaching fresh Heights in
Ukraine and seconds later there's an
even bigger one
that's the sound of debris raining down
on the car roof
shrimp Cloud created is captured by a
driver on the other side of the road
Imagine The Naked fear felt by those in
the middle of all this
this was the north side of danipro one
of Ukraine's biggest cities
and the attacks here were replicated
across a string of other cities
throughout the country
it is by far the most widespread series
of Russian attacks since the start of
the war hitting 11 key infrastructure
facilities in eight separate regions
quite a record with the war now in its
eighth month
this was the crater caused in denipro by
that double hit in a residential area
there are several apartment blocks
around and it's on a busy bus route
this wave of Russian attacks across the
country has dramatically upped the ante
and suggests far from giving up the
Russian leader has once again doubled
down
the residents trying to piece together
their lives are full of Fury
and they're feeling even more terrified
after this barrage
um
but the strikes which rain down in the
heart of the capital city were no doubt
the kremlin's main aim
the rain down they did smashing into
traffic Junctions and burning Vehicles
as workers made their way to offices
this was attacking the very nerve center
of Ukraine's leadership the man and his
team leading the string of Battlefield
successes and counter-offensives
this was hitting electricity supplies
water provisions and Communications
aimed at making life even more difficult
for those enduring this Invasion as
rumors swirled about his death the
president emerged
foreign
[Music]
among the Russian leaders attacks one
aimed at kiev's Landmark pedestrian
bridge narrowly missing a walker
mid-route
somehow the bridge remained intact
despite the Russian leader implying this
was in retaliation for the bridge
explosion in Crimea a few days ago
the missiles hit a playground in one of
the capital's main Parks popular among
families with children
and millions saw a young student
narrowly escaped death on her way to
University
but amidst the fear and horror the
indomitable Spirit of the Ukrainian
people was on full display helping each
other on this the very worst day the
country's seen in months
the capital's residents took to
underground shelters again but their
response was this
foreign
songs sung heartily and with Great Gusto
many of the capital's residents had
returned in recent months believing
their Capital was safer now
the whistles the sound of another
missile flying in one of 80 across the
country the Russian leaders bent on
making sure they keep flying into
Ukrainian territory and keep wreaking
havoc
difficult to imagine but there could
have been even more destruction more
flattened homes and deaths
yet the Russian leadership's threatening
more attacks
there's no end in sight to this misery
in fact it's just escalated several
notches Alex Crawford Sky News in
Ukraine